okay so you can see even in the
the triangle get up
from a marshall point of view you start
doing weird things
but they don't feel weird to you because
you don't know the martial context you
can't
imagine all the things that an aggressor
can do to you
so you don't know when you deviate from
the form
that you are partially vulnerable
there's no context for your movement
and the only thing you have to rely on
is your
capacity to replicate the teacher's form
but that's nearly impossible
it's it's and i'm not talking about your
body is different from your teacher's
body
that's that's not what it is that you
see
the technique from the ego tripartite
it is constantly being interpreted
and placed in your own egocentric
context so
it's placed in the context that
redefines
the eye and so
the art is outside of the ego tripeptide
so that
deviation is always that it's always a
deviation
so you can either
take decades of
entering yourself into sparring context
where you realize
oh god my head's too low or oh
man i'm i'm heel weighted or oh
i shouldn't be going forward right now
um
or you could just replicate the
teacher's
technique more purely less through your
ego tripod
but i find a happy medium between
understanding the martial context
it's very important that you understand
the martial context because
you're going to fill in the blank just
automatically you always will
you will fill in that blank that context
without the marshall experience it's
going to be wrong
it's going to be a deviation from the
get-go anyways it's going to be wrong
so let's look at
the tessabaki from yesterday okay
let's look at it marshally and the first
thing to note
is aikido kihon wasa is not
a one-to-one
training application ratio
meaning a guy that grabs my wrist
does not deserve for me to kill him by
feloniously battering his head with the
planet
it is a training device and within the
training device
you have some martial
strategies and tactics not all that you
will need
but some and if you don't have those
some
you will never be able to do the art
martial it won't happen so we have to
understand
this sum um
this what i'm talking about here is not
the totality of what these training
drills teach you
we're just looking at the marshall side
of things so yesterday
um we had the ikea adhesion part
you need a nike adhesion skill you need
the internal skills
so you are working on that you do have
an angle cancellation on that arm you
have to understand basic concepts
of checking the guy out through
diagonals that cut through his height
width and depth
and then you also have this notion of
i'm going to control from two
points okay i want to know how wherever
i'm touching i'm controlling the guy
from two points
by controlling i mean that i am
affecting his
uh the relationship between
his center of gravity his line of
gravity and his base of support
i i am manipulating it okay
um we're now going to go
to katata but it's going to be the same
okay and we're going to be able to
understand one more thing from
kosadori there there is a notion that i
work
up the body from outside
to the spine line this is a very common
strategy
in martial arts so i'm passing
all this in front here passive that's
what i want
so when you're doing closer doing
it's just one arm and pass
his head to the other arm
when you're doing contact you're going
to have that same angle
of cancellation you're going to have the
same adhesion
which you'll passing it from one arm to
the other arm to the head
that's what you want
oh this is
[Music]
yes
the question was ask her are you are you
are you pulling him
no you're not calling him even though
he's gripping
i'm not using his script so i'm not
using this
picture move that he has here and the
width of my hand to make him move
so he can he can open his hand and
you can do it that's the i key
the internal aspect okay i have to be
able to adhere causes adhesion
and it was that that lets me
get the two points those two points are
controlling him
so i don't have to do this arm
manipulation
if i am required to do the arm
that means i need to control his arms
combatively and that only makes sense to
somebody
who does not train combatively because
when you do you'll find out that is
extremely hard to do
to get someone's arm okay every
new um law enforcement officer i ever
trained
always thinks it's possible and they
realize
after a few arrest attempts it's not
possible
or you guys in your network
are you just killing arm bars like this
and figure fours and kimuras no no
you're
not right so it's as simple as
he's he's trying to manipulate my arm in
some way right
and just people just pull out their arm
so when you are grip dependent
you are arm dependent and your martial
viability is going way down
and that's not the
the strategy as i said is to manipulate
the relationship between his center of
gravity his line of gravity and his base
of support
not to manipulate his arm
so when we go to this technique
this is the same thing you have to have
that ik adhesion there you're not grip
dependent
but on the other arm here you don't have
it
at all you don't you don't grab them
you're doing the same lifestyle adhesion
so i decision adhesions
and then i go back to the same thing
just
two points of control but not grabbing
not opening from back here
that was it you worked the drone
[Music]
this part here is another thing you're
trying to learn
but it's not that first strategy
how do i clear the stuff between him and
me
what stuff his limbs how do i get past
his limbs and get to spinal control okay
try it again okay so uh again
this is i'm moving one
two head one two hey
one two head okay that's that's the idea
so that means that when i bring him here
this hand is going to continue him going
with that adhesion
it's not here he stopped and then i go
behind him because again
if you fought people you'd realize
going this is not the opening the 12 6
line is not the opening
several things happen okay either
forget the wrist rep because it was
never about a wrist round
but i have a guy aggressive
well he's going that way and i'm going
that way
we're going to pass each other okay or
he's going that way i don't necessarily
pass him
but now i'm going to be fighting his
forward progress
okay and again if you don't ever fight
you don't realize you can't just grab
people from the back of their body and
chuck them down
okay
so you want to look for
one more adhesion and now partially
you've set up the eevee angle
which is not at the 12 6 line but
at the 3 9 line okay
so interest yourself with setting up
this three nine line
and then you'll probably interest
yourself with actually doing the first
marshall tactic pass him to the other
hand
as opposed to
check him and then you're going to do
this he should still be going forward
he goes forward into the technique
[Music]
forward
try to get that three nine line for your
entry
the next marshall skill
is once i've passed his uh spinal
spinal control to my other hand
is how to manipulate
the distal end of the lever so it's
distal because it's
far from his center of gravity okay but
how to manipulate the distal animal
lever
in a way concentric with the art so
it's got to abide by yin yang theory and
non-contestation
okay so because you have this forward
progress to him
when you do this little circle here
his forward progress
is going to start creating
um an adhesion on my hand
as is doing a kind of centripetal
pattern in this spiral okay so
it's not that i tilt his spine
it's that i'm going to do this
little thing like this you see
i want to feel his centrifugal energy
harmonizing or being capitalized upon
with my centripetal energy do you get
that
so that makes this one wrong
right and that also
makes these tilting things right
and again if you spar you realize
oh i tilted the guy but i can't do
anything with it you know or
i can't tilt the guy because he just let
go of the arm control that i had
things like that okay so i'm doing the
first
like adhesion arm pass spinal control
and getting his
forward process to generate
an integration with my centripetal
energy okay
so one two four
one forward
[Music]
and that way this arm is does not become
so mechanically a slave to the arm
manipulation
okay because it's not really the major
engine
in that kazushi you see
well
[Music]
and again don't think well this is what
i do when there's an arm grab
don't think this is what i do when i
pass the arm it's just a skill
it's a totally unique skill set in the
same
drill now i'm going to work on this
and now i'm going to work on this
i'm going to work on that too
let's go backwards yep so we'll leave
the head control off for a second
let's just look at this arms okay so
his he has the um
hinge at the elbow and he and then he
has this ball socket joint
at his shoulder okay and so
uh when when you're below the elbow
and you try to control him it's very
easy for him
to open his arm you see he absorbs the
energy that you had checking him
and then the same thing when i go uh
above the elbow but i'm on top of his
arm the ball and socket joint
doesn't give me the control i want so
when i control
his body i'm going to control it
here above the elbow making that joint
irrelevant
to what i'm doing and then uh
near the ball and socket joint so that
as it as it moves all around it's i can
stay with it
do you see it doesn't immediately go
underneath me
so here and then in the same way as on
the neck control
i'm using the
harmonization i'm doing between his
centrifugal energy and my centripetal
energy that's making that stuck on there
so they're not independent the two of
the two of them
are what's moving down okay so don't let
that arm go dead
all right anytime i'm down below here
you're dependent upon the aikido culture
of some weirdo that keeps his hand
stuck to yours which is not a nike
adhesion that
is a masquerade of a traditional
historical internal aspect this
keeps his hand there and and you tell
him some stupid thing like
you know he's protecting himself it's
like there's all kinds of ways of
protecting yourself rather than sticking
yourself to me
as the attacker as a defender okay so
above near the ball and soccer joint
okay
um because now the more that i'm not
doing that
the more dependent i am on that arm or
on that stupid training culture
and then the less martial my technique
is going to be
meaning these aspects i will not be able
to bring
outside of the forms training and into
more live environments so you're going
to see
whether you were armed dependent or not
as we move up to ski
okay so he's gonna do uh jodonsky
boom okay and i have to do
the arm pops the arm pops
and then that part is exactly the same
so
here comes his ski boom
reach out arm hop
[Music]
this isn't a self-defense technique this
guy punching me
that's not what's happening but you're
taking away your grip dependency
you never started with the grip depend
with the grip
so he goes boom there's that
not three lines
[Music]
okay so now
we'll work on those skills uh
outside of that cultivation environment
okay
so let's say um i don't disaggress i'll
find it
okay so here he did that
so here is my pass that i want
you see oh this arm's going to pass
pause
and then i'm going to do that little
circle
okay so we're here won't pass this
little circle
uh
[Music]
okay let's go all right okay
so again you're just you're not you're
just drilling
you're still just drilling you're still
um this concept of get
see all this stuff get get rid of it and
uh
start affecting that relationship
center of driving line of driving basic
support okay that's all you're doing so
he he did that i'm i'm weaving outside
right so pop
you're you're out here like this okay so
the first time
my hand happened to be on on the inside
you see
so i'm gonna use the two hands to keep
him going
so it's not it's not a pairing and then
i try to get back here
because you can't get back there as you
sing you can't get back there
okay so uh as we go
this is going like that but
everything can shrink now as as he has
way more energy
than in the kihon okay everything kind
of shrinks
but everything stays the same
in principle so boom and i know and now
i will not be able to do the head
manipulation of eddie minagi because he
has no more forward progress
okay so your your timing is here
he has to be going that way for me to
use my centripetal
energy which is why i can't stop him
i need him to go that way and then the
eye could he should make sure he goes
that way
and it's casting him
[Music]
sometimes uh i am just was here
he came that way brought behind her and
it was this immediate
all right maybe i'm here
maybe
you just go right to the second part
okay
but you'll see that this this skill set
boom starts to open up not opening there
so in this drill uh i just
i want to start learning the skill less
and less
in a structured way so you're going to
um i'll i'll be okay
okay and don't take the first one
let happen okay so i'm gonna
keep doing my aggression
and so you see he didn't keep me going
forward
okay so let's see
he's keeping his aggression right
don't don't worry if you get tagged
don't worry don't worry that's not a big
deal
in this drill okay but you don't have to
get tapped
just keep working and eventually
you'll feel it boom keep going
boom keep going
boom
[Music]
and you'll find it on the shiro tank on
the sheet of tank
[Music]
don't worry you'll find that get back on
the inside for me
won't fall straighter straighter
straighter
keep going
get on the inside get on the inside good
inside
[Music]
boom boom boom
okay kind of work the drill like that
you're getting a little bit of
desensitization to um
it's really up to you to keep the
energy frame okay all right
remember i'm trying to drill a marshall
tactic
i'm not fighting the guy right so
he has to set up he has to uh
um do something that i would be on the
outside and hence pass
past the arm and then find the head okay
so if if he's going to start going on
the end um there you go he's just here
or he's not penetrating it at all
do you get it so your uke has to set up
the drill
just like in kihon waza was
prescribed set up the drone okay
so the same thing when i'm here i i'm
gonna be okay
i'm not gonna go i you would never
i'll tell you right now never pass that
arm
aggress ed me okay
so the drill for uk is he keeps setting
that
up come on
there it is
so you see i could not stop
so that he keeps getting it in a more
fluid starting point
so i keep going
and he wants to relax tighten his
movement
shrink the windows for the timing
you're a lot of fighting a lot of
contestation
so go this is what that felt like keep
going
that's straight dude i'm gonna if you're
gonna
change the drill i'm gonna change okay
you got it
okay so one straight
you're here keep going you see there's
no
non-contestation of your jiu-jitsu so
you feel that difference so always
yielding
yielding and hearing find the head
don't peel it on the straight line over
he goes
so yield on the spiral diagonals spiral
boom there is going to be one string
boom there it is
okay so fix yourself okay i'll take you
off the mat
okay so what what we're seeing now is
he's going
go go
and you're starting to go like this okay
but
you're in front of the guy now this is
not the technique
because he's supposed to be over there
so that i can do my
triple energy he's going forward
your problem if you give me the ademi
tencon version of a imei
is again you filled in the blank okay
uh the tencon is is not where the
kazushi
this same thing is happening here okay
it's not uh that i'm going like this and
then he's going down
that's not what's happening in the ten
conversion okay
so i'm doing the first one
right and there's all this weight
you see it can easily happen so the
weight
he starts to fall here i can't bring him
back that way
the weight falls here and i non-contest
right so he give me some weight here and
i move out
[Music]
it's not this streamlined
okay so in this drill though we're not
doing the 10 con version so let it go
forget it
he's going he's penetrating boom
boom i'm on the straight line hey fix
myself get some angles
boom there it is that's it
get some angles and that's it
the arm past the harmful that's it
that should be my drill if you're
finding yourself drinking
you're doing it wrong there you go